大家好,我是彩虹
今天
先去咖啡店
可能會去港南
要先去聖水的一間早午餐廳
然後吃完之後有可能會去江南晃晃
到時候再看一下計畫
今天有一點下雨
蠻麻煩的
然後我早上還去跑步
才剛洗完頭髮
然後感覺又要濕了
在搭計程車
我每次說要走路
超時又說不要
他說走路過去二十五分鐘要嗎
他說不要
今天的造型
好漂亮喔
昨天韓國朋友推薦我們可以來吃這間貝果
這裡的貝果看起來很好吃耶
這間貝果在馬鈴薯湯的對面
我覺得不錯
然後就是你選了貝果之後
然後還可以來加熱
蠻好的
我好像是第一次吃這種
就是鹹的貝果
這個是披薩口味的
我們現在來吃吃看這個貝果
我來吃吃看
Chelsea姐姐的好不好吃
三明治貝果的概念
會滿好吃的
說說你十年沒來韓國的感覺是什麼
覺得非常的好
因為我有一個非常專業的地域
語言障礙
這很好耶
而且我以前好像沒有來過
聖水嘛
因為以前聖水都還沒有
順水是疫情之後才開始興起的
以前是明洞嗎
對啊 以前是明洞
然後以前新沙洞也蠻紅的
可是現在就是有點掉下去了這樣
它甚至連never map都沒載
全程我倒了
不是我載了 我還是看不懂
因為never map它只能輸入韓文
然後如果是你輸入中文或者是英文的話
其實沒有辦法
但我聽說最近韓國好像準備要開放Google map
但是呢 Google Map 還不夠完成
所以你只能用 Naver Map
所以我覺得學一點點韓文的字
其實還是有幫助的
她昨天晚上睡前看我在打韓文
然後就跟我說那到底什麼東西啊
她說圈圈叉叉你怎麼看得懂
然後我就回她說
啊不是啊 這就四十個拼音而已啊
這四十個拼音不會很難
這四十個拼音背起來
你就可以輸入了
今天的穿搭Point呢就是
裡面是一件 Bra Top
然後外面是一件就是
Settle My 的一個針織衫
上面呢就是 Artist 的帽子
那其實帽子這一點我真的非常的喜歡
因為我覺得穿上它
如果我今天全部都是一個黑色的風格的話
那穿上它就會有一種
欸 point 的感覺
對
然後再搭上 Gentle Monster 的墨鏡
其實其實只是一個造型而已
沒錯
然後你可以開到後面的 point
非常的可愛
後面可以綁蝴蝶結
也可以讓就是兩條線自然的推放
沒錯
來韓國就是每天都非常的認真打扮
又來到這一間店了
每天外面的那個景好漂亮
雨真的實在太大了
適合等一下找一間咖啡廳坐著
好好笑喔
這個人剛買完一個包包跟一個鞋子
然後呢又是在買了一個包包
準備要走的時候
然後決定又要再買一個包包
對
帥
可是這間真的很好逛
我也很喜歡
今天只是想要拍這間店啦
但是一個不小心好像變拍藍鋸一樣
這間店真的很可愛
推薦大家來逛
下雨天
然後等著
這間看起來超漂亮的耶
我們現在呢就是
雨真的太大了
所以就找了一間漂亮咖啡廳
現在已經五點了
我們坐了三個小時
滿滿把雨太大了
哪裡都去不了
嗨 我們新朋友
有點頂公
好久不見了
在這邊什麼時候
韓國前
那一年多了耶
一年多沒見的學生
然後在首爾間
等一下一起去吃飯
這是我親自做的美甲 跟她做的美甲
然後它是我們兩個的綜合體耶
耶
這個…
三明治的辣
還有這個 給我一碗
啊…
你吃辣嗎
我吃辣
很辣
全部都很辣
三明治的辣
對
對…謝謝
韓國朋友跟我說這一間超級好吃
他跟我說如果你們有就是兩三人以上的話
那就可以點刀削麵 然後加上海鮮煎餅這樣
有 今天三個人所以可以吃
那你要教我一句韓語
好 教妳一句韓語 妳想學什麼
我想學這個很好吃
這個很好吃
這個好吃
這個我會了
推薦什麼
推 喔妳說問對方
對對對 請店員推薦的話
嗯
請問可以吃嗎
請問
可以吃嗎
哇 這個煎餅不得了耶
怎麼看起來那麼好吃啊
就是上一次一個人的時候
沒有辦法這樣吃
要死啦 我要吃
讚啊
哇 它恰恰的
恰恰是什麼
脆脆的
喔
不要擠 不要擠 等一下
不要這樣
不要擠 不要擠
所以妳沒有吃過這個嗎
我沒有吃過這個耶
好酷
哇 好好吃喔
哇 這看起來超大
因為我們有三個人
而且這個麵配那個泡菜超好吃的
泡菜嗎
就是一起吃 我覺得很剛剛好
我們剛剛吃完那個ガーリックス之後呢
然後就來了ONIA這間咖啡廳在聖水殿
其實我很久之前大概來過了三四次吧
很久沒來了
聽說有一個新的就是杜拜巧克力
然後我朋友說很好吃
工業風感
朋友說這個很好吃
杜拜巧克力
胡巧克力粉
所以不會太甜
很好吃耶
可以啊
叮叮叮叮叮
叮叮叮叮
自己快快的
你確定可以用嗎
已經不知道了
好啦 掰掰
韓文小教學到此結束
再見